We have major breaking news into CNN.
Actor
Alec Baldwin has just been indicted
by a New Mexico grand jury on charges
connected to that fatal 2021
shooting on the set of the film Russe.
CNN's Josh Campbell
joining us
now on this, along with legal
analyst Areva Martin.
Josh, first to you.
Tell us what we know here. Yeah.
So once again,
Alec Baldwin now criminally
charged once again.
Obviously,
we had been reporting earlier
on after
that fatal
shooting in 20, 21
that the actor had been
criminally charged.
Those charges were then dropped.
Prosecutors at the time
said that
that was because new
evidence came to light in the case
causing questions
about a piece of evidence.
A law enforcement
source at the time told me
that that was because they learned
that the weapon
that was used in
the shooting had been modified
in some form.
And so again,
those charges had been dropped.
Prosecutors at the time
said, though,
that if they gather new information
that determine culpability
on the part of ALEC Baldwin,
they would then possibly refile charges.
We're learning today
that did indeed happen.
A grand jury in the state of New Mexico
returning this two count indictment.
I'll read you
the two charges specifically.
Count one
is for involuntary manslaughter,
negligent use of a firearm, count
to involuntary manslaughter
without due caution or circumspection.
Now, the original prosecutor in the tape
and the case told me that
as part of this lengthy
investigation, authorities
have determined
that there was this
culture of unsafe practices
on the set
of that movie
with past
reports of accidental discharges.
It's worth
pointing out that actor Alec Baldwin
all along has indicated
that he did not pull the trigger
on that weapon.
He has maintained his innocence.
We just got a statement in here
to CNN, a very short statement
from Baldwin's attorney
saying that
they look forward to their day in court.
But again,
the breaking news now, actor Alec Baldwin
once again
now criminally charged in the fatal
shooting on the set of the movie
Rust in 2021,
which killed cinematographer
Helena Hutchins.
And Areva, how are you reacting to this?
Well, these are stunning turns of events
because Brianna,
we know that Alec Baldwin
probably thought that this case
was completely done once
the other prosecutors
who were assigned to the case
dropped the charges against him.
We know that he's gone public
talking about the case.
He has maintained his innocence.
So now to be charged
with some of the same evidence
and the same gun, the same issue
that the prior prosecutors
had with respect
to the gun, its issue
having been mishandled or somehow
damaged by
the FBI is going to be interesting
to see how this new team of prosecutors
are able to establish the evidence
that will be necessary
to get a conviction in this case,
because you still have this gun
that was somehow mishandled by the FBI,
which is a central piece of evidence.
The interesting part about this
to me, Areva,
is that
officials have not been able
to determine
how the live ammunition found its way
into that 45
caliber revolver
that it was manufactured
by this Italian company
that specializes
in the
kind of reproductions
that are used on on films like Rust.
How does that
potentially complicate the process
of proving in court
that Baldwin is guilty
of two counts
of involuntary manslaughter?
It's going to be challenging, Boris,
because the prosecutors
will have to prove willful disregard.
And you are right.
Not only have
the investigators of prosecutors
not been able to determine
how nine bullets or live ammunition
ended up in the gun.
They don't even know
how live ammunition ended up on the set.
That's still a very unanswered question.
They have not been able to,
even though the armorer,
who has also been charged,
she set to go to trial
starting in February.
Apparently, she has not provided
any information to law enforcement
about how that live ammunition
arrived on this set.
We know that people should not be killed
in the making of a movie.
This was a tragedy
that should have never happened.
Two people have been charged.
And now with Alec Baldwin, a third person
being charged.
Clearly, someone is responsible
for the death of Miss Hutchins.
But the investigation
seems to have been so shoddy
that it's not clear to me
that anyone will be held
criminally responsible Yeah.
Josh, how much can that endanger things
when you have
at least
in this kind of legal accounting here,
so many people held accountable
And it's really unclear
which one should be.
No, it's a great question.
You know,
I posed this to prosecutors early on
and they said that
they will conduct this investigation
and hold accountable
anyone that they believe was responsible.
But it's worth pointing out,
after those initial charges came out,
we heard from numerous
legal experts who were quite stunned,
actually saying that you know,
we can understand charging
someone who
was responsible for a live round
being in that gun.
But there's just been this question
about an actor,
someone who was told on set allegedly
by one of the prop
masters that this weapon was, quote,
cold, that it did not have
any type of ammunition in it.
That person
then handed it to Alec Baldwin.
And so this is going to be,
I think, a central part of
Alec Baldwin's defense.
Two parts.
First, you know,
should an actor be responsible
for then checking the gun
and then no knowing the difference
between a live round of ammunition
and a so-called dummy round.
We know that there was a live round
of ammunition in there, ultimately.
There's also the question
about the integrity of the gun itself
as the reviews,
which I was just talking about.
Whenever the FBI was brought in
to conduct
an analysis of this gun,
they did multiple tests on the weapon.
The central question there was,
could this gun go off
if Alec Baldwin did not pull the trigger?
Of course, he has claimed all along
that he did not pull the trigger.
What the FBI determined
through their testing is
that gun
could not have fired
unless someone actually pulled
the trigger.
Now, as Areva mentioned,
the gun did get destroyed
during the course of that testing.
I read through this lengthy report
from the FBI analysts in Quantico.
What they indicated
was we're talking about an older gun
this isn't a prop gun.
This was an actual functioning weapon
that through the course
of multiple rounds
of testing
the gun pieces
inside the gun ultimately failed
causing destruction.
And that's
what Alec Baldwin's team
seized on, saying, look, the gun itself,
there were problems with it.
But, you know,
I went back to law enforcement,
to the prosecutors asking
They indicated that no, at the time
that the weapon was used on
that said
analysts believe
that it could not have been fired
without someone actually
pulling the trigger,
which I think finally is
why as you look at these charges,
this all seems to center around
negligence.
I mean, it's right in count one,
negligent use of a firearm.
If you are someone
who is in possession
of a functioning firearm
and you pointed at someone
and you manipulate that weapon,
whether that's the trigger
or the hammer on the gun
and it goes off and someone dies,
are you responsible
prosecutors here
saying ultimately, yes,
or I should say a grand jury coming
now and saying, yes,
that Alec Baldwin should be indicted
on those criminal charges?
Of course, we'll wait
and see what happens
next in the prosecution.
There was always this question about,
you know, early on
whether Alec Baldwin
would plead to anything.
His team was adamant
that he wasn't
playing to anything
that he determined or believed
that he was innocent of these charges.
And again,
that statement
we just got from his attorney
say that they look forward
to having their day in court.
And then the final point
I'll mention is Areva
centered on which this is so important
is that we're not talking
about a separate group of prosecutors
from the original team
that filed charges.
This prosecution
has had all kinds of issues.
At one point,
there was one person
who was brought on to the prosecution
team.
It turned out
she was a Republican legislature
in New Mexico,
a legislator in New Mexico
who is also working on the case.
The Baldwin team cried foul.
They're saying, look, this
probably smacks of politics.
And so bottom line, a new special
prosecution team was brought in.
That's the team that ultimately presented
this to the grand jury.
The grand jury
finding that, yes,
Alec Baldwin
should be indicted on two counts.
All right, Josh and Areva, so it goes on.
We'll continue to follow
it along with you.